determinar la media la mediana y la moda
del siguiente conjunto de números y ahí
están ahí nos dan los números así que si
alguien nos habla de la media en
realidad se está refiriendo a lo que
comúnmente llamamos el promedio a veces
también es conocida como promedio y
vamos a aprender que en realidad hay
otros métodos para calcularlo pero
simplemente sumando todos los números y
luego dividimos entre el número de
números que había ese es el promedio o
la media entonces la media sería 23 más
29 más más más 20 más 32 más 3 23 más 21
más 33 más 25 y esto hay que dividirlo
entre el número de datos así que
contando tenemos 88 números de estos así
que tenemos que dividir por 8 y
calcularemos esta respuesta voy a usar
la calculadora para hacerlo digo podría
hacerlo a mano pero así nos ahorramos un
poco de tiempo
de esta forma así que tengo 23 más
29 más 20
20 32
23 más 21 más 33 más 25 y a ver eso que
nos da la suma de todo eso nos da 206
ahora hay que dividirlo por 8 entonces
esto ponemos 206 entre 8 y tenemos 25
puntos 75 así que la media es 25.75 y
esta es una manera de medir como la
tendencia central de esto otro método es
con la mediana y esto consiste en
determinar cuál es el número que queda a
la mitad si los ordenamos de menor a
mayor
aquí el más chico que aparece es el 20
tenemos 20 luego el siguiente es 21 21
aquí hay un 22 no no hay 22 así que
tenemos 223 verdad eso y eso siguen
tenemos esos y allí tenemos un 24 no
tenemos 24
tenemos 25
ponemos 29 luego sigue 32 y luego 33 así
que cuál es el número de en medio bueno
tenemos 8 números bueno esto ya lo
sabíamos así que en realidad va a haber
dos números en el centro verdad si
tienes si tenemos un número par de datos
en realidad hay dos que están cerca del
centro y para realmente calcular la
mediana tendremos que promediar estos
dos números porque a solas no pueden ser
la mente la mediana abajo del 23 hay
tres números y arriba y cuatro y del 25
abajo hay cuatro números y arriba y tres
entonces hay que promediar estos dos
números y el resultado de ese promedio
es la mediana así que tenemos 23 más 25
entre 2 es 48 entre 2 que es 24 y aunque
24 no es ninguno de estos números la
mediana es 24 así que este es el número
de que representa a la mediana otra vez
es una manera de representar o de pensar
la tendencia central verdad y no hay una
única forma de hacerlo hay varios
métodos para calcular digamos el centro
el centro
si tuviéramos que representar estos
datos con solo un número bueno podríamos
utilizar estos dos por otro lado tenemos
la moda y es simplemente el número que
aparece más veces en este conjunto de
datos ahora todos aparecen una vez
excepto el 23 que aparece dos veces y
por eso 23 como aparece más que todos
los demás entonces bueno de hecho todos
aparecen una vez entonces el 23 es la
moda